Gea stands for Trans Am its track attack
know it stands for tits and ass you
could not quit now you're trying again
which is quitting she was like you who
went to the Frampton concert Fred Jon
Gary Steve Steve Brandon oh well that's
some group let me think John Hein hey
Fred Steve Brenda no Robin and you all
sat together at the prompting concert
yeah wow what a cool group thing that
cracked me up was there was one dinner
reservation at first and then Steve
found a more appropriate play I found a
cooler place people go it's very trendy
yeah you know the first reservation was
a little too club' nobody's allowed and
this new place he chose that was going
to be much much yes we're going to a
cool place cool do you get together with
Brandon Oh a lot he's like my concert
date and who determines the guest list
when all of you go together
Steve the concert let's get all the cool
guy the tasting menu come on it's the
best tasting menu in minute where'd you
end up going to dinner
legacy records yeah
legacies the coolest you eat your nachos
off a vinyl it's really cool if we could
only find a logo in Manhattan Frampton
concert was like East Coast long ago and
the best thing John did not join us for
dinner and we're all figuring that he
looked at the menu and said never
and you went get a hot dog at Madison
Square Garden and he did he did right
yeah yeah hey God committee to Mel P you
take a five-year-old just so you know
Howard Johnson he came straight from
work he didn't look at the banner please
stop along the way lon mm-hmm soon as we
got to the concert I think would you buy
Joe two hot dogs - two hot dogs that's
healthy
I am Frampton was good I spoke to Robin
on the weekend she gave me a report she
said it was really good trams and was
really good oh my god you left out the
Fred part and well that didn't happen
you know as soon as Frampton had
announced that he was on his final tour
I said to Steve I want to go to that
concert
oh and so he knew I was going and then I
I didn't realize all the other guys were
going you don't realize all the cool
guys were going legacy records the way
they dressed like DJs is that true that
would be great meat loaf with legacy
records meat loaf actually ate the
meatloaf with legacy I'm an idiot
I love style you know when I went meant
to ask him is he vaping again oh we
really need to check in yes I here's
your pen gives you juice want me to
throw it out right now it's a big moment
do it a year strong enough so I'll throw
garbage right now and you're doing do it
before he tells us what would you what
we do babes I'm with you on that
he better be honest I guarantee you he
babe because if you're not honest we're
gonna catch you anyway Fred what do you
think you know what I'm gonna give him
the benefit of the doubt I'll say no
he's quit no way he doesn't have the
willpower sound do me a favor I don't
mean to bust your balls all day just
give me the answer I quit baby so fred
is right you haven't had one vape and
you you Robin and you alright cuz I did
Saturday night I was at a poker game and
I did vape a little bit okay so let me
clarify the answer bread is wrong and
Robin and I are
fred is right that I quit and you know
we know you quit but you you broke down
and baby but I quit so Fred's right one
day
sandy does this go on all day in your
life Howard everybody let me ask you
something
I quit eating chocolate ice cream yes
but on Saturday night I had chocolate
ice cream did I quit eating chocolate
ice cream you quit but you had a relapse
all right so yes you didn't quit
well like I quit I had a relapse and I
quit again so I talked yet did I quit
yeah yes I had did I have a real on
being so in other ways when Robin and I
posed a question and I said to Robin I
you know Robin said I believe Sal could
not have the willpower to stay off babe
right and that he went back to it and I
said Robin I agree with you
yes and then Fred said I'm thinking
style actually stayed off it we both
can't be right yes Fred violently right
and you and Robin are wrong because I
quit I had a relapse and acquitting as
you quit then you started again no I
started a little bit and then I went
back to the quit mode no the simple
answer is you could not quit now you're
trying again which is quitting I'm in
quit mode no no you quit I quit and then
you started again and then I went back
to quitting so which quit stop saying no
every time we finish vaping you've quit
vaping until your ready to vape again
Sal yeah I quit breathing but wait I
just took another breath did I quit
breathing let me ask you me what
happened when you started again what
happened was it was at poker game
Saturday night go ahead and we were
drinking and we were playing poker
who's we my friends we have a poker
tournament there are people who hang out
with
can you believe it no honestly I did I
would I would be afraid of losing my
brain cells so we would you know you
drinking your gambling we're having fun
some guy there is vaping and then I
baked a little bit and that's it then I
stopped beeping the next day and then
and I told my children as well I said
look I'm stopped vaping I said I did a
little bit and I said but I go I want to
continue to quit dreaming mara no I want
to continue to quit I want to know how
many days off babe have you now
well Saturday no no you smoke right so
Sunday much so today's a day and a half
one day a day in an 8 Robin a day in an
8 its track attack all right let's go to
Mike Mike here's your chance to get on
the board okay what does ta stand for in
the Challenger Series trans Automotive
can we accept that John yes we'll accept
that answer
all right the or Trans Am would have
been acceptable we have a point it's
track attack well ta says here ta stands
for trans not on a challenger it doesn't
and he said trans auto mode what do you
say a track attack gentleman is Ronnie's
challenging he's challenging your answer
Ronnie I'm sorry but the Challenger it
stands for Trans Am it's a it's a
tribute to the Trans Am no it's not did
not allow you use the word Trans Am on
their car yes that's why it's but it's
the definition is not Trans Am you're
arguing with the judge yes I am I'm
sorry Ronnie my results are final saying
you say on the wrong car then no you own
a challenger Trans Am no Antoinette's
route challenge at EA and what is the T
ace - raccattack you're wrong
okay I'm wrong all right Mike you up one
point Ronnie has zero but now is
Ronnie's firm
running powered yard interrupt you we
have multiple sources here that says
TransAm and actually when you type in
track attack hot wheels comes up
oh so it's with a little car for
Ronnie's toy car you have a license
height well my road test you either tell
me he passed the written test he passed
the written test that guy's the
learner's permit
Riley Howard he's been driving with his
learner's permit who's driving with him
nobody okay Eric listen to me carefully
you cannot drive with just a learner's
permit you have to have a licensed
driver with you have you been on the
highway wait till I get to where I have
to go Bengie talked to Eric yesterday
when he was driving we're driving
yesterday you liar because it's hands
what you just said you never talked on
the phone
wow I can't even believe this if he
passes Friday the DMV needs to be shut
down let me ask you a question what's a
double solid yellow line mean so you
can't cross over pretty good all right
so I'll bet you a hundred bucks he
passed okay you're on can I get it on
that sure you want another hundred yeah
take your damn right why not sorry honey
anybody else want free money wrong
Robin's handing out money to everyone
Eric you better pass you how fast have
you gotten your car up to 175 really I
was up to 80 Howard there's a couple of
things going on with what what Eric's
saying that does not bode well first of
all he said he drove to Connecticut the
other day personally I don't think with
your learner's
we've already pointed that out
unfortunately unfortunately Hasmik gosh
Benji said when he spoke to him he
thought he was alone in the car yes ya
know both of those where you been Eric
is cracking Gary now that was pretty
good
[Music]
[Music]
see
ha
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
soft swinging I told SiriusXM the
company we work for Sirius XM Pandora
that I would go out to California to
inaugurate their new studios they want
me out there and and you know we're
gonna do some interesting shows they're
already been planning him then what was
the weird thing I heard about Brent I
think Brent's gonna go to LA I don't
understand Brent's marriage I mean I'm
not gonna it's weird he's supposedly if
he goes to LA he has permission to [ __ ]
girls in LA without his wife hair he
doesn't even have to have permission
it's an open well I think half he it's
just when he gets home he has to tell
her about she's getting closer and
closer
open marry yeah I don't know I think
there's no marriage Brent what's the
deal when you go down real quick you're
able to [ __ ] whoever you want LA correct
and do you have to like let's say we're
somewhere and woman's to say Brent I
gotta have you if you have to quickly
call your wife or he just [ __ ] her and
then tell her about it when you get home
I've got pre permission to [ __ ] her and
tell her when we when I get home Wow I
have to tell every detail how did we
know you're gonna remember every detail
well I've got a 122 working memory and
by the way she similarly while you're in
LA she can [ __ ] whoever she wants
correct here Wow yes dude what is gone
hey hey listen whatever I I hope it
works out come up did she bring it up no
well she she brought it up before like
if I go on the road right um I can or
two do anything she was like you have
pre permission to have sex well that'll
bother you on some level not at all like
like hey but should my wife not want
that you know like man should be a
little jealous this resemble a marriage
in some way yeah I mean we're best
friends right well it's just when it
comes to sex anything goes yeah when it
comes to sex it's a completely separate
thing Julie was telling me his theory is
you will not get laid in LA and
Kaitlyn's gonna [ __ ] like 15
he's going around by saying that to
everyone now you might as well know what
he's saying what else is he gonna say he
also said that we weren't gonna swing
either yeah true it was wrong about that
right head wrong as per the usual well
he thinks he forced you into swinging
thank him he can't force anybody into
anything right truly your theory is
Brent will not get any action in LA he's
not close he's got a better shot of
closing a three-picture action movie
deal in that Lathan get laid out there
and I'm gonna watch the hole I'm gonna
I'm gonna be on you I'm gonna be
monitoring him when you go out to get
laid
I'm coming with you I want to see this
once and for all your assignment is to
trail Brent no matter what and I'm with
that not to get in the way come on you
can't throw salt in my game buddy I'm
rooting for you I hope you can say
you'll help him from him I don't want
him to keep his distance I don't want
people to know that we're even there
together all right fair enough
all right fair enough and also Howard
I'd like to request that we have the
same room - oh sure no thank you so you
can't sneak out on I want to see Brent
in action outside of here I don't need a
lot of time to hang with Brandon if
you're gonna observe him in his natural
habitat
I got him room with the girl well you
can have separate bedrooms needs to be
right next in fact you need to share a
bed I need some time away from this I
cannot I mean I'm around him all day I
heard your plan is to go to the Rainbow
Room to pick up girls you have a channel
actual plan yeah I'd love because that's
where I'm comfortable that's where I
would hang out when I lived in LA and
I'm cute I want to see what's his outfit
like when he goes to the rainbow bobbing
to show off his tattoos close a deal
like which metal shirt is he wearing are
there any pins I have a lot of questions
right all right well yeah we're gonna
put you guys in a room together oh
please I need some time away we just
ruined the trip Ellie
all right boys well we look forward to
the LA trip and hereby curse off
swinging and full-on swinging newts
Capades
we want to know it all and Brent will be
swinging
Ireland Ireland hey Sal have you heard
from your buddy the psychic Long Island
psychic didn't she contact your dog for
you or something
no my dog came to me my yeah my dog
visited me in a dream was it was a
beautiful thing my dog passed away on
his dog visited him in a dream or did he
have a dream now well it's a dream
robber but it's called the visitation of
somebody passing so you had a dream and
you think you were visited by your
actual dog I was visited by my dog it's
called a visitation let me ask you
something don't you think a visitation
would be you're awake and then you see
you don't you don't well you I can have
a dream about my dog let's say it's a
scenario my dog's a three-round catching
a frisbee that's not a visitation okay
my dog visited me in its moving form in
my arms and in my dream
alright dream you're holding your dog
and it's glowing
yes it's glowing white and in my dream I
acknowledge is this a visitation I want
it cuz I want to validate this I went in
leaned into my dog and she licked my
face and it felt extremely real and my
dog was there and glowing so was a day
before because you're out of hurt the
death of a one-year anniversary because
it was a dream but she was glowing it is
no longer a dream it is a visitation
it's a technically it's a dream yes when
you're in a subconscious state yeah
that's the easiest way for spirits to
visit you so the dog visited me well you
don't think it was just a dream you say
you say it was not just the dream it was
a visitation it was a yeah because the
way the dream was structured a dream
could be any scenario how do you know so
much like how do you know the way it was
structured yeah how do you know the
visitation procedure or the structure
cuz I read up on this I do a lot where
do you read about this I read online of
course we found out about how to treat
your cholesterol that went horribly
wrong on our phone is Sal's dog falling
from heaven
hello yes bark once if you visited Sal
bark twice if you did not oh you did I
want you to bark once for yes twice for
no is Sal a dumbass oh okay thank you
that's not my dog how do you know my dog
would you know my dog said goodbye to me
Howard well my dog passed away really in
English no in in Yugoslavian Robin how
did he do that yeah Robin the dog was
born in America Robin so he said goodbye
with his eyes all right you ever hear of
projection what is projection you say
you heard of it well projection is where
you could communicate without without
auditory response really yeah it's not
projecting want to take another guess I
[Music]
said to JD he's telling me he likes
paying his credit-card debt
he doesn't pay it all the way down he
likes having credit card debt yes I said
that's crazy
why not just pay it off I pay the big
you get 30 days free so as you go
through the month and you make all your
purchases you're not getting charged
interest yet yes once you don't make the
full payment then you start getting
charged interest are you listening to
this JD I'm listening everywhere what do
you say repeat that's all I heard JD
what did this guy just say about
interest 30 days if I don't pay
immediately that I'm stupid or whatever
he says is that what he said I don't
think you hear everything thank you just
leave me alone
all right everything's fine did you get
any information that you didn't know a
certain amount of money in the bank
available to me but but what you're
doing is paying the credit card company
money you don't even have to pay them if
you just pay the bill you're buying
something for a certain price and then
paying more for it okay well I'm stupid
and that's my choice all right I don't
want to tell you you're choosing to be
stupid
oh yes that's what you're saying yes
your choice is be stupid yes
why would that be your choice because I
don't know any better I don't know you
really don't I just just know what I'm
doing I've done I've been doing and I've
surviving you're saying you like to pay
credit card companies money no I know
it's an interesting angle you feel bad
for the companies why because I don't
like talking about this why he goes I'd
like to have certain monies in the bank
have to have Chipotle and I can choose
money yeah but wait a Ferrari JD is
saying I have the cash to pay off the
debt but I choose not to because I like
keeping the money in the bank
I have emergency Tito's money
here's wolf from Philadelphia yes Wolfie
hey I was curious to know when JD was
initially hired who was the person that
interviewed him hurt his verbal prowess
and decided this is the best candidate
for the job I believe the way JD was
hired JD was an intern here and then JD
was particularly good at getting these
clips together and he sort of formed his
own job he started to take it on on his
own am i right Gary yeah he was a
actually used his head and was a
self-starter that was maybe the only
time he has ever had take as taking some
initiative and I have to say he's
terrific at it he really is really good
and very proud of his job I know what
this guy means Wolfie JD is the kind of
kid he can't imagine being in the room
going you know you get scared you're
like a Frankenstein monster but could
you imagine for a JD's initial interview
so tell me what is it you like doing
[Music]
your movie director studying video this
is JD's resume oh gosh let's see I just
like his description of his prior
employment I highlighted it JD you know
Jamie har Mayer okay this is addressed
amigos related experience writer and
director of film shorts for Lake Gibson
high school TV productions we get those
various positions on Silent Witness a
16-millimeter student film directed a
scene instructed actors and crew all I'd
love to get a pay for that okay look
there wasn't much everyone said and say
all right go employment si si assistant
manager
movie gallery Lakeland Florida I checked
the movies in and out that customers
rented receive product in the computer
system exported product out of the
system help during inventory cleaned up
store made late calls etc that's good I
like that
I had to is my job so like I go oh well
I see here you have related experience
tell me about that related experience as
to how the movie gallery work I dealt
with people and I you know it was hot I
was a miracle
I have three standard interview
questions is there any chance I could
ask them the JD what yeah that'd be
great this guy again Jamie tell me about
yourself well I'm like you know I'm nice
I think I have some sort of intelligence
overall intelligence interview what was
interviewing for a job you know I I do
have some sort of people's skills
whenever whenever I have to talk to
people um that's fascinating where do
you see yourself in five years i I have
no idea right now
Oh hopefully uh being a director but
we'll see Howard my third question was
what are your weaknesses but I think he
already after that what are your
weaknesses one of my weaknesses Venus's
weakness I said weaknesses I'm shy I
don't know weaknesses I realize your
whole job interview lasted like not even
30 seconds well if he asks you three
questions and you did
terribly wolfy came up with another
brilliant bit there you go
Oh take it easy these are typical
interview questions well I I if I if
I've to do an interview I will prep
myself and get myself you know ready for
an interview somebody on the air for a
caller I have a good sense of humor
that's a weakness again spontaneous
spontaneous JD's tell me about yourself
well on the internet I'm known as the
badass huh all right wolf well that was
very informative thank you okay they're
brilliant bill wolf thanks daddy I love
you yeah [ __ ] off I love this story
let's call this the bagel caper
according to what I heard out in the
hall ronnie has a special he calls it
his desk it's it's a filing cabinet so
Ronnie puts his bagel on the filing
cabinet all wrapped up he'd walked away
for a while he came back and the bagel
was opened up the wrapping was off of it
he blew a fit and started screaming who
touched his bagel not only is he but
there's two other security guards all
stands right by this filing cabinet
nobody knows who touched Ronnie's bagel
but their security and nobody knows how
do you not know who touched your babe
what do you mean your security I went
out to the store the guys they went out
to the kitchen to get a drink go ahead I
went out there I made a bagel wrapped it
up nicely
what do you wrap it in a bunch of paper
towels okay wrapped it up real good yeah
put it down on top of the filing cabinet
which is your desk yeah my dad special
desk right right tell the story I come
back bagels all unwrap the paper brows
are gone what is the bagel sitting on
there was one little napkin sitting on
top
nobody's knowing funny [ __ ] with your
food you are you out of your [ __ ]
that time oh I'd be livid I find it
incredible that three security guards
don't know who walked into the room were
you guys I wasn't in there I was gone so
why don't you ask you are the two
buddies who what who [ __ ] with your
bunks sure they know who did it and I
know who did it go ahead it was only one
person there so he loves to [ __ ] with me
because he thinks everything is a big
joke so who was it Perlman Perlman Mike
Pullman Kurt for an explanation he was
on the air once this is a guy that works
first that was shot was Mike [ __ ]
with Ronnie's bagel trying to [ __ ] with
my head you're trying to rile me up
everybody's after you yeah Mike what's
going on here I agree with you 100%
never never [ __ ] with anybody's fool no
I would and I wouldn't do that
raise your right hand I'm gonna swear
you in like Corey Lewandowski did you
[ __ ] with Ronnie's bagel no this morning
were you at any point thinking to [ __ ]
with Ronnie's bagel not did you walk
into the room and Ronnie's bagel was
there all wrapped up I didn't see him
wrap it up I'm wrapping it up in okay so
Ronnie's not crazy when he said he
wrapped up a bagel because I was
thinking maybe just forgot yeah all
right okay all right you have children
right yes I swear on your children
they're my child and you weren't in on
it you know what do you think had what I
think happened was this I think he what
he does is he puts a number of paper
towels on his bagel and I think he only
put one on because when he came back how
many were on it don't lie to me man no
how many papers were all there first of
all there was a napkin on top a napkin
at all that was there and that's all you
did in the first middle [ __ ] I
wasn't paying took the paper towels
which I always do I took three or four
of my wrapping up tight and that's how
it was laughs is it possible that the
bagel wasn't as tightly wrapped as you
think they were gone napkin was sitting
on a flat on top of it which I didn't
even put there you and two security
guards stand there and no one knows who
went in the room and cried I went to get
something to drink what you're right and
when I came back this was all done did
you say to them I was gone three minutes
maybe so who could have walked in three
minutes at those two guys didn't study
no idea ghosts [ __ ] with me because
you'd love to rile me up always
constantly be Royals you are yeah he
loves doing it you know what it is it's
you I know it's you by the way did it
the bagel wanna know what do you [ __ ]
tell me any different
no security what you [ __ ] one of your
security guy buddies thinks that you
forgot how you rap but no oh yes what I
think have no way I think you know
[ __ ] way Howard I did see him doing
something with with the paper towels and
napkins whatever it was I took a number
I think him up tight I think what how
could the guys not see who walked in I
didn't even your own I'm saying you
might be forgot where I [ __ ] did like
I do it every [ __ ] Wednesday don't go
but Ronnie we're only gone three minutes
with your baby what's the joke if
someone messes with you this is the
[ __ ] joke this is a [ __ ] joke let
me ask you where's the rest of the paper
towels that you said why don't you look
around did you see are they in the
glamour spell I have no idea I didn't
wanna to investigate that's I don't need
no [ __ ] investigation I don't need no
homeland security this is rental JMO I
have a problem all I know is somebody
[ __ ] with it that's all I know and
that's all I care about
I know well I didn't go up well I have a
big problem you have a team of security
people in this building that don't know
if someone did in fact [ __ ] with your
bagel did you ask them you're the
[ __ ] head of security
well you're not everything definitely
stupid also what are the things that
Ronnie rapped it wrong they just think
that Ronnie's forgetting the way he
wrapped it right yeah I just laid a
napkin on topic that's called wrapping
Gary go [ __ ] yourself
you know I'm starting to believe you
forgot I'm not trying to [ __ ] your head
up you might think you [ __ ] believe
that
forget the bagel where's my dildo oh
wait it's in my ass
[Laughter]
[Music]